two teams and he's pretty much on pace
for that again another turnover mcgirl
gives to walker
up top for cunningham and he puts it in
with two
[Applause]
[Music]
reeves hands the finger roll won't go
here comes cunningham trying to go coast
to coast
[Applause]
and it's a one-point game the clock is
not broken
it's cunningham time down the stretch
here we go and draw some defensive
attention now
matthew myers switched off on him and
he's taken that on and a
really nice move to get to the middle of
the floor
and then spin back mark vital started
out on cunningham then mitchell then he
was passed off to matthew meyer and he
just
took him middle and then spun back
[Music]
to put them back up three what a pro
shot there former zag who's now playing
in europe all
seven guys could be drafted from
montvert academy
running hand working the offensive blast
and a chance for a three-point play
for quick jumping take a look now he's
gonna go wedge in
garrett first time no go second time
stays with it
he's gonna get a chance to get three
right there
15 second differential between the shot
clock and the game clock
[Music]
[Applause]
first of all he goes out and demands the
basketball i mean you can hear him
clapping
give me the ball i love it it gives me
the chills
and then he's just so under control
that league is loaded
[Applause]
he's not just caught up with his stats
and caught up with the fact that he's
inviting the first player
to rotate over look at him rotate over
cunningham triggers the inbounds throws
it closer and they
get the bucket what a momentum builder
for the cowboys
cunningham in the last minute he got the
post up
got a bucket and he's been outstanding
since that moment
what a play and that's just the
defensive breakdown
he knows that called her pretty well
he's made a few of those this year from
deep
a turnover
[Applause]
take a look right here that's six foot
eight with a 7-2 wingspan
and give him credit two teams and he's
pretty much on pace for that again
another turnover mcgirl gives to walker
up top for cunningham and he puts it in
with two hands
second time we've seen an oklahoma state
guard just fly through those passing
lanes throw it up let kate cunningham go
get it
that's a heck of a first buck in here
[Applause]
see the elevation takes the contact just
a
big time play and a really nice pass
from rondell walker
he'll likely come up and set this screen
and then die
[Music]
cunningham saves it up ahead
walker
well there's that defensive iq
that turns into offense how about the
fact
mark that there was not one dribble
[Music]
block save
throw ahead let it bounce for me and
finish what up it's your boy adam lefkow
do you like that content i know you like
that content hit subscribe
for more of it from bleacher report